toujours en direct entre 18 et 19h sur
tv fil pour faire le point sur l'actu
dans les yvelines avec le 7-8 nous
poursuivons vous l'avez vu avec la
chronique que sports anthony on va
débuter avec l'aj auxerre qui va devenir
le partenaire de l'oas et elancourt
expliqué donc tout à fait le football
professionnel va arriver dans le
département l'eau et celle en cours va
signer prochainement un contrat de
partenariat avec l' aj auxerre le fameux
club de guy roux pour en parler le
président de l'ot et c est avec nous sur
ce plateau monsieur le duc bonsoir
bonsoir
alors tout d'abord une première question
d'où est venue l'idée de ce partenariat
avec le club de gairaut alors l'année
dernière nous avons contacté tous les
clubs de ligue 1 de ligue 2 en essayant
d'avoir un partenariat
le but étant de renforcer nos écoles de
foot de s'appuyer sur des gens qui ont
des compétences autres que les nôtres et
donc on est tombé juste au moment où
auxerre recherchais un club dans les
yvelines puisqu'il cherche un club dans
chaque département d'île de france et
non qui cherche un club amateur dans les
yvelines
donc on est tombé vraiment au bon moment
et qui roux a donné le dossier donc et
monsieur k bine qui a traité la faire et
donc le partenariat sera signée le 18
septembre à la mairie d'élan pour c'est
à dire qu'ils ont besoin de jeunes
véritablement là pour alimenter auxerre
dans les prochaines années
maintenant que le club évolue en ligue 2
tout à fait il continue toujours à
s'appuyer sur la formation il espère
toujours mettre au moins deux jeunes
issus de cette formation dans l'équipe
pro actuellement ce qu'ils cherchaient
surtout c'était avoir une vue sur les
joueurs département ils ont déjà des
vues sur les joueurs de ligue ils ont
les recruteurs au niveau ligue
il n'avait pas de recruteur au niveau
département donc en ayant un faisceau
comme ça de gens sur le terrain pour
pouvoir pour signaler des joueurs de
qualité
ça leur permet de vous voir tous les
joueurs susceptibles de rentrer au
centre de préformation
mais alors au delà du fait
de cet avantage de la détection pour la
g auxerre il ya aussi ce partenariat qui
va concerner directement l'eau et celle
en cours puisqu'il va y avoir des
tutorats des déformations c'est ça pour
le staff technique du club
voilà tout à fait le lit recruteur et un
cycle savent technique d'auxerre va être
un appui pour nos éducateurs nos
éducateurs iront se forme et se
perfectionner chez eux ils seront là en
soutien il a droit aussi à des
entraînements nous donner des conseils
donc là en appui avec on le sait
d'expérience d'auxerre kiné qui n'est
pas un bête en question les rassurer
nous c'est un partenariat est gratuit
vous ne donnez pas d'argent l aj auxerre
pour qu'ils viennent chez vous non non
non non non il dono pas d'argent il n'en
donne pas non plus puisque c'est tout
est gratuit un bien sûr c'est uniquement
à transfert de compétences et alors du
coup ça fait un peu vases communicants
chacun y trouve son compte puisque l' aj
auxerre va venir puiser un peu vos
meilleurs joueurs comme c'est déjà le
cas je crois il ya déjà un joueur qui
est parti ensemble de préformation
exactement donc savoir un joueur qui
s'appelle françois xavier fumée il est
parti à partir des u15 et en aucun chez
nous donc formé depuis le plus jeune âge
il a actuellement 15 ans 15h15 voilà
tout à fait donc il actuellement en u19
nationaux
donc il est titulaire il a même fait un
match amical vendredi avec l'équipe
première dont quelques les pros il ya
joué un quart d'heure en fin de match
voilà donc c'est un joueur qui en plein
air en pleine réussite actuellement je
pense qu'il a un avenir aux allergies
auxerre il est avec ce partenariat vous
espérer augmenter justement le nombre de
licenciés au sein du club
c'est une c'est un objectif aussi bien
sûr mais le premier objectif surtout
c'est de renforcer l'école de football
avoir une meilleure formation toujours
puisque l'école de football
c'est l'avenir du club et combien de
licenciés actuellement vous avez donc
les 670 c'est ce que ça a baissé par
rapport aux à ces dernières années je
pense à l'épisode équipe de france 2010
on avait parlé de l'impact sur les
différents clubs on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs alors là nous ont pas
vraiment l'avez ressenti dans les
inscriptions n'ont pas vraiment puisque
on a l'effectif qui est toujours en
progression notamment avec l'apport des
féminines puisqu'on a créé l'équipe
humiliée à 12 ans on tenir vos crédits
qui fait unis 10,9 en plus donc on a un
apport de féminines les jeunes ceintures
sable malgré tout on nature et stabilité
au niveau des effectifs les othéens en
termes d'éducateurs c'est toujours des
éducateurs qui sont formés au club sont
dire que c'est des enfants du club et du
coup après qui passe de l'autre côté de
la ligne de touche alors majoritairement
c'est ce qu'on veut c'est la politique
du club c'est de dire voilà on est les
joueurs au club il arrive aux seniors ou
au moment où 19 et après ils participent
à la vie du club qui vont participer on
faire des stages formés au niveau
éducation et surtout être là pour nos
jeunes et c'est votre premier
partenariat de ce type justement avec un
club professionnel
oui c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire du club il y avait une
obligation ou pas est-ce qu'à une
obligation a maintenant deux ans imposée
par la fédération à nos coûts nous
sommes liés avec des clubs
professionnels
aucune obligation laisser totalement
lips et giresse et initiatives du club
est-ce que les autres clubs de saint
quentin en yvelines font de même vous
avez les discuter entre vous parce que
là vous vouliez avec un club situé un
petit peu loin de saint quentin en
yvelines un petit peu loin du
département est ce que vous discuté
aussi avec les autres clubs du
département oui tout à fait douze clubs
du département sont des partenariats
alors certains avec ce show d'autres
avec avec psg bien sûr on notamment
traduit d'être lié avec p g
après c'est très difficile d'avoir été
dépassé avec les clubs il faut savoir
que beaucoup de clubs pros ont déjà des
liens avec des clubs amateurs
et c'est vrai qu'il faut vraiment une
opportunité comme cette poignée auxerre
faut que ça réussisse et signature le 18
septembre
le 18 septembre raison de l'église saint
guirons vient à la guy roux était prévu
il devait venir malheureusement il est
toujours possible tendre une chaîne
cryptée et donc à un match de coupe
d'europe ce soir là donc on n'aura pas
la chance de le voir
d'ailleurs il ya un match aussi
nationale en cette fois si demain votre
pronostic pour le mot la rencontre de
l'équipe de france et l'histoire des
victoires à zéro anthony alesi preuve 0
pour la france 2 0 pour la france on
vérifiera ça lors de la prochaine page
sports merci jean pierre leduc d'être
venus en tenue on va continuer cette
chronique le sport